>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Claudia Avala: My
name is Claudia Avala.
I am -- I am with the Hispanic
division at the Library of Congress
and I am honored to present to you
bilingual author and illustrator
of children's book, Lulu Delacre.
[ Applause ]
Lulu Delacre was born in Rio
Pierdras, Puerto Rico in 1957.
She's the author and illustrator of
many award winning children's books
and nonfiction novels for teens,
including her most recent work
that she will present today --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
-- Olinguito from A to Z. Unveiling
the Cloud Forest, published in 2016
by Lee and Low Books,
Arroz con Leche,
popular songs in Rancho [phonetic]
Latin America, Vejigante Masquerade,
El Bossy Gallito, How Far Do
You Love Me, The Storytellers:
La Velita de Los Cuentos,
Arrorro mi niño: Latino Lullabies
and Gentle Games, among others.
Lulu Delacre had her first formal
art training when she was ten
in Buenos Aires, Argentina, where
she was encouraged and taught
to draw by her mother's
closest friend.
She studied in the Fine Arts
department at the University
of Puerto Rico, and then
she continued her studies.
In the guarded [phonetic] of
Graphic Arts in Paris, France.
I have to translate that
because I don't speak French.
Delacre's the winner of
several Pura Belpre Award Honors
and American's Book Award
for Vejigante Masquerade.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Lulu Delacre: Good morning.
Buenos dias.
>> Buenos Dias.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Lulu Delacre: You've heard
a lot about me, but you,
we are here because we
are celebrating a very,
very special occasion.
We are celebrating, Dia -- El Dia
de los Ninos/El Dia de los libros.
That is Children's Day/Book Day.
We celebrate this all
across America.
This is the day that we celebrate
books that talk about all children,
all ethnicities, all
backgrounds, all languages.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Raise your hand if
you are bilingual.
Hands down.
So --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I am going to talk about how
is it that I created this book,
Olinguito from A to Z,
Unveiling the Cloud Forest.
But you know what?
We are going to start
from the start.
Do you know, what is the very
first thing that you need
in order to write a book?
And it's not pencil,
paper, word processor.
No things that you can touch.
It is something that
comes from here.
What is it?
And I want a hand, just a hand.
Yes? An idea.
That's exactly what we need.
Behind every single book
in this amazing library --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And this is my idea
behind this book.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I wanted to create a book
with a Spanish alphabet.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I didn't know how to go about it.
So one day, I opened the newspaper,
[foreign language spoken] the
Washington Post by the by the way.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I Found an article.
And this article talked about this
amazing animal called olinguito.
Can you repeat that with me?
>> Olinguito.
>> Lulu Delacre: Now
all by yourselves.
>> Olinguito.
>> Lulu Delacre: Fabolos, oliguito.
So I read about this animal
and I said, oh, oliguito?
I have my oh [foreign
language spoken].
But then I needed to find
all the other letters
from the Spanish alphabet.
[Foreign language spoken] I
needed to find all the animals
or amazing animals and plants
that coexist with the olinguito.
In The Cloud Forest of Ecuador.
That took me a long time, and
before I tell you a little it,
and I read you the book, I want
to tell you a little bit about,
the olinguito and about
The Cloud Forest.
The olinguito is a
small, soft animal.
They say that it has the face of a
teddy bear and the tale of a cat.
It is very, very small.
Actually this is the
exact size, very small.
And it lives in the
cloud forest of Ecuador.
It is nocturnal animal.
Does anybody here know
what nocturnal means?
What could that mean?
Hands, hands.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
Over there.
Nocturnal, what does that mean?
Nocturnal [foreign language spoken]?
Yes, nocturnal means
[foreign language spoken].
No. [Foreign language spoken]?
>> Si.
>> Lulu Delacre: A nocturnal animal.
Does it -- does it -- does it
come around during the day?
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: No.
At nighttime?
>> Yes.
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes.
Nocturnal, it comes around at night.
But not only is the
olinguito a nocturnal animal,
he lives in the canopy
of the cloud forest.
That means he doesn't come
down from the treetops.
And -- and why is it that it took
so long to find this little animal?
Well, it took very,
very long because I have
to tell you now a little
bit about the cloud forest.
Why do you suppose the cloud
forest is called the cloud forest?
Why do you suppose --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
That's exactly right.
[Foreign language spoken]
cloud forest.
It's filled with clouds, clouds and
fog and mist covered the forest.
Therefore, think.
Put on your thinking caps.
Thinking caps on.
Do you think that it's very
easy to see an animal this size
when it's all very, very, very dark?
There's no lights at
night in this forest.
We are not in the city.
We are in a forest
[foreign language spoken].
There is a forest where
it's no light whatsoever.
Do you think it is very easy to
see an animal that comes only
at night in a very dark forest?
And this dark forest is also
covered with mist, fog and mist.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: No.
You have the right answer,
[Foreign language spoken].
So that is why it took so long --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I am going to tell you how
is it that that happened.
A group of scientists,
not too far from here --
actually a group of scientists,
[foreign language spoken]
that worked in the
Smithsonian Institution,
they worked for ten years finding
and determining the different --
different characteristics
of a certain animal
like the olinguito called
the olingo that comes
from the same family,
family of the raccoons.
And -- and one day this
scientist find out --
These zoologist found out that
there were some skulls, you know,
the skulls, the bones that
were a little different.
Some skulls that were labeled
olingo's that were different
and some bones, some
pells, you know the fur,
that was a little different too.
And this zoologist began to suspect
that -- that it was mislabeled,
that this specimen that he had
been studying in the Museum
of Natural History
had been mislabeled.
And conducted some very
special testing, DNA testing.
And you know what he found?
Do you want to know?
That this was not an olingo.
It was a different animal.
So this scientist gathered a group
of other scientists, friends of his
and they went all the way down
south to the country of Ecuador.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They wanted to know if this animal
was alive and well in the forest.
Okay. Now I'm going to stop
and I am going to read you --
well, actually I'm going
to tell you the story
of The Olinguito in Spanish.
And then, we'll see the story
develop -- shown in the --
on the screen in English.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And now, let's go into the forest.
I went to the forest.
I went to the forest in
the Andes of Ecuador.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Where the olinguito lives.
And I went there because I
wanted to see with my own eyes,
not only the olinguito, but I
wanted to see the amazing plants
and the amazing animals that
coexist with the olinguito.
I didn't tell you something
very important,
and that is that in a cloud forest,
not only the cloud forest is known
for -- That's me in
the cloud forest --
for the clouds and mist that cover
every single part of the forest.
We have a lot of plants
and these plants --
Many of these plants are air plants.
So you have the clouds and the mist.
You have the fog covering
all over the forest.
You also have many
plants that are air plants
like the bromeliads
that you saw there.
Remember when I started --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
What you see on the --
on the screen right now,
those are bromeliads, air plants.
These plants -- this is one of the
characteristics of the cloud forest.
The cloud forest is known to have
a lot of mist, a lot of humidity
that -- that actually nutrients,
they nourish all these air plants
like the bromeliads and the orchids,
and -- and also the orchids,
bromeliads, ferns, the lichens,
all those are air plants.
So you can see here the -- the water
and do you know what
you see up there?
>> Bananas.
>> Lulu Delacre: Who
is eating the bananas?
>> Olinguito.
>> Lulu Delacre: Who
is eating the bananas?
>> Olinguito.
>>Lulu Delacre: I can't hear you.
>> Lulu Delacre: Indeed
it is an olinguito.
Do you know that I stayed four
hours of the night waiting
for the olinguito to arrive,
because I really wanted to see one,
and I was staying in this
lodge in the cloud forest,
and the manager had promised me
that I would see an olinguito.
And I was staying there
just three nights.
So I had just three
nights to see it.
I said if I don't see it, I am going
to be very, very, very, very sad.
So I was standing there
with my camera,
and I had some friends
in the beginning.
But by hour number four,
I was there all by myself.
Everybody had gone to bed.
I was still there with my camera.
I wanted to snap a
picture of the olinguito.
When it appeared, I was so
nervous that my hands were shaking.
I couldn't take a good picture.
That's why it's kind of fuzzy.
But I'll tell you why is it that the
olinguito is eating those bananas.
See, the bananas don't grow at the
altitude where the olinguito lives
in the cloud forest of Ecuador.
Bananas grow at a lower altitude.
They grow in the jungle,
in the rain forest.
So, the manager of his loft, he --
he bunches of bananas to the trees.
Remember I told you the
olinguito doesn't come
down from the canopy of the trees.
Remember I told you --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So, the manager tied
bunches of bananas,
and this is such a special treat
for the olinguito that sure enough
when it smells the bananas, it
approaches, and there it is.
That's how I got to take a picture.
So, now we're going to
read the book in English.
Come join the zoologist from
Washington D.C. as he searches
for the elusive olinguito
in a cloud forest.
Does anybody know what
does the word elusive mean?
What does it mean?
Elusive means it's hard to find.
Do you remember why the
olinguito's hard to find?
Why was it hard to find?
Why? Yes, the girl in red.
>> Because it only comes at night.
>> Lulu Delacre: It
only comes at night.
Does anybody remember why
else it's hard to find?
Only comes at night and
what about the cloud forest?
What about that it's hard to see
when you're in the cloud forest?
Why is it?
What is it?
Yes.
>> Because it's a cloud.
>> Lulu Delacre: Exactly.
Absolutely, you have
so many clouds and fog
and mist, it's very hard to see.
So, high, high up in the Andes,
blooms that brilliant forest
embroidered with bromeliads,
home to crab and snail,
hummingbird and cottontail
and a dozing olinguito,
dreaming the day away.
And I -- I can hear some
of you are very excited
because you've already
spotted olinguito.
Yes, the olinguito is up on
that tree, but he's sleeping.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I am going to tell
you something else.
This is something that you
don't know yet or maybe you do.
But in every single page of the
book, there is the zoologist.
Remember the scientist that went to
search for the olinguito, remember?
>> Yes.
>> Lulu Delacre: So, I hid [foreign
language spoken] I hid the zoologist
in every single page of the book.
Okay, this is how we're
going to play the game.
Okay, listen to me.
I'm going to read -- I'm going
to read and then if you see --
if you see the zoologist
which is actually a silhouette
of a man, you raise your hand.
But you raise your hand with --
you know what, you raise your
hand without saying a word.
Is that okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Okay, so let's see.
Can anybody see the
olinguito on this page?
Raise your hand?
Where is it?
>> Sleeping on that thing.
>> Lulu Delacre: Correct.
He's hiding on the top right.
Hands down.
So let's see.
This is letter C and
D. Let's turn the page.
This enchanted forest
in Ecuador is a festival
of flowers and fresh water springs.
Raise your hand if
you see the zoologist.
And it's hard to see because in
this picture, he is camouflaged.
The silhouette of the
man, the zoologist,
the scientist is camouflaged.
You can see.
Let's see where is it?
[ Inaudible Answer ]
Okay. Where is it?
Where is it?
Can you tell?
Do you see it?
Who can help her?
Don't stand up.
Just tell me.
Where is it?
[ Inaudible Answer ]
That's exactly where he is.
It is back there in the
background, actually,
above the letter E.
That's where he is.
And you know what, if you
don't see it well later,
I'm sure that you'll
be able to take a book
and open it and find for yourself.
Hands. Only hands, no words.
Okay, so -- But have
I read this page?
Not yet, not yet.
I need to read the page.
It says: "I gaggle off cock of the
rock gathers to display and dance.
He's usually hurdled
with birds, mushrooms
and have you ever seen
birds like that?
Aren't those amazing birds?
The red and blackbirds.
Aren't they amazing?
They are amazing.
So raise your hand if you
can see the zoologist,
only if you can see the zoologist.
And if I call on you, you tell
me where is the zoologist, okay.
Let's see.
Yes?
>> It's over above
like under that --
>> Lulu Delacre: That's
exactly where he is.
It is over that big, huge leaf
and behind in the background,
so the right of the red
and black cock of the rock.
So, I have to tell you something
very special about the ants.
Do you see the ants?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Ants,
hormigas -- hormigas.
Ants in Spanish is hormigas.
Hormigas begins -- hormigas begins
with the letter -- What letter?
[ Multiple Voices ]
Okay.
Okay, calm down.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So hormigas in Spanish begins
with the letter H. It's a letter
of the Spanish alphabet
that is a silent letter.
That's what we had
some kid saying, oh,
but some of you said
"H" right away, hormiga.
This is not any kind of hormiga.
This hormiga, it's an army ant.
Hormiga guerrera, but not
any kind of hormiga guerrera,
not any kind of army ant.
These army ants -- these
army ants, they actually come
out in swans of 200,000 individuals.
They blanket the forest
all black, all black.
They go up the trees.
They all go up the branches.
They even go inside the
homes of the locals.
Could you believe it?
My guide told me when I was in
the cloud forest, my guide told me
that her parents as soon as they
can hear the army ants come,
have you ever heard an ant walk?
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: So imagine
how many ants are walking
if they can hear them walking.
As soon as the locals hear the ants
walking, they leave their houses
because they literally
come into the --
the doors and windows and
they ate whatever they want.
And the locals know not
to mess with these ants.
They just leave their houses and
come back when it's safe to be
in their homes without ants.
So this is the army ant
that is why there --
It's not any kind of army ant.
Questions at the end.
Promise, okay?
[Foreign language spoken].
We're going to --
So, we were here.
He's usually hurdled
with birds, mushrooms
and incredible insects
and a resting iguana.
He watched fig and coffee trees
sprout and grow in this jungle,
sprout and grow in this garden.
And -- Oh, oh, oh, I
forgot, I forgot, I forgot.
Okay, raise your hand.
This is very hard to see.
I -- I don't think that you
can see this wallet is here.
But let's see.
If you can see this wallet,
just raise your hand.
And you have to describe
to which side
of the illustration you
can see the silhouette
of the zoologist, the scientist.
Let's see, let's see.
You in the -- in the center, yes?
Yes? [Foreign language spoken]?
>> Right --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Right. [Foreign language spoken]
yes, to the left of the letter I,
E. [Foreign language spoken] E
[foreign language spoken] iguana.
Okay, so --
-- down by the riverside, kermis
collar [phonetic] ginger bloom.
A lizard lies on lichen,
[inaudible] line the vine
and the light is drizzle.
The light is drizzle falls.
Falls, I know, fall on springy moss,
a monkey, a butterfly and a moth.
Clouds, fog and mist nestle
in the noble cloud forest.
Somebody was upset because I went by
and didn't show the
zoologist and the other one.
So, can you see the zoologist here?
Raise your hand.
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes.
>> Over the side of
the cake [phonetic].
>> Lulu Delacre: The side of --
>> The cay.
>> Lulu Delacre: The side of the
chion [phonetic], yes of the flower.
The side of -- the left hand side,
the side of the cake, correct.
The left hand side of the cake
and right there by the river.
Can you see it?
Okay, let's see the next one.
Can you spot the zoologist here?
This is very hard to see.
It's almost the color the ground
where he is -- where
he is walking on.
It is very small and hard to see.
Let's see, somebody in the
back, somebody in the back.
Yes?
>> Over there in the middle.
>> Lulu Delacre: In the middle.
Can you tell me the
color of the ground?
The color of the -- What color
is the ground he's walking on?
>> A butterfly.
>> Lulu Delacre: [Foreign
language spoken]?
Purple, yes, that's
exactly where he is.
Right there in the middle
underneath that beautiful butterfly.
[Foreign language spoken]
We have two -- This is interesting.
This -- A wonderful
-- a wonderful thing
that I love in the Spanish language.
Butterfly in Spanish is mariposa.
Here we have mariposa
[foreign language spoken].
We have a butterfly and a
moth, because in English,
you say moth for the
nighttime butterfly.
In Spanish, we call it mariposa
[foreign language spoken].
So Spanish language.
Asters paint a path gold.
[Foreign language spoken]
amid their sweet scent.
And hidden among -- among orchids,
the olinguito serves
a spectacle bear.
Oh, look at my olinguito.
Let's put it here.
So, let's see.
What letter of the alphabet is this?
Can you raise your hand if
you can tell me the name
of the letter in Spanish?
[Foreign language spoken]
This is the letter in
the Spanish alphabet
that does not exist in
the English alphabet.
What is the name of this letter?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So for this letter, we don't have
any words in the English language.
So I am going to read it in
Spanish so you listen to the sound.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Asters paint a path gold, okay.
And, oh, did we -- did
we spot the zoologist?
Did we spot the scientist here?
No we did not.
Let's see, can anybody find it?
Over there, yes, in the corner.
>> -- In there were
next to the flower.
>> Lulu Delacre: Next
to the -- That's right.
Next to the bossy flora, next to
the [foreign language spoken],
that's exactly where it is.
A hummingbird sips nectar
in this part [inaudible].
As the gleaming gets out
quietly a lights on cedar.
And I see so many hands.
It seems that you've
spotted the zoologist.
This one is very easy to spot.
Let' see, who do we have here?
Over there, yes.
>> He is behind the hand.
>> Lulu Delacre: It
is behind the palms.
That's correct, behind the wax palm.
Did you see the beautiful
[foreign language spoken]?
Did you see the [foreign
language spoken]?
That's another amazing species here
that coexists with the olinguito.
Now what did you notice
about the colors of the sky?
Have we noticed something?
Raise your hand.
Have we noticed something
about the color of the sky?
Do you think the sky is changing?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Do you think
it's getting to be evening?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Let's
see what it says here.
Let's see what it says.
Glass rocks jump on branches and
the little ray of sun settles
on a toad and a salamander.
Do you see the zoologist?
>> Yeah, I see it.
>> It's on top of the --
it's standing on the
mountain next to the plants.
>> Lulu Delacre: Exactly
against that pink sky.
And you may not have noticed, but
that zoologist is holding a camera.
What you think he's going
to do with that camera?
Let's find out.
Okay, so by evening, oh my God.
By evening a tarantula
-- a tarantula tiptoes.
Do you see the tarantula?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Are you
scared of tarantulas?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Lulu Delacre: Where's
the zoologist?
>> Sky, in the blue sky.
He's so little
>> Lulu Delacre: Yeah.
Wow, I am amazed that you could
spot that zoologist because actually
that zoologist, it is very, very,
very tiny, and it's up on that hill
against that lavender sky.
That is where the zoologist
is, still looking for --
He's still looking for what?
What is he looking for?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
A viper he sees.
Do you know how a viper is?
[Makes snake sound].
Can you do like a viper?
A viper he sees, and as
the olinguito turns around,
the zoologist from
Washington whispers, "Wow."
Why do you think he's saying, wow?
Why? Why? Do you think
he's been looking
for this olinguito
for a very long time?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes.
Do you think he's finally,
finally found it?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Let's
see what happens next.
Beatles, needle bark next to
the borough of carpenter bees.
This is the letter X.
And in the letter X,
listen to me because the letter
X in Spanish is beautiful.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Oh I see that everybody's very
excited about the zoologist.
So we are going to find a zoologist.
So where is zoologist?
Let's see.
Who can see?
Who can spot that zoologist for me?
Somebody that I haven't called.
Oh, right behind -- He
was -- Right behind you.
Yes? I call him.
I have very poor memory.
Who has -- Okay, great.
>> It's right next to the
tree with the flowers.
>> Lulu Delacre: Oh wow, amazing,
and we're so far away
and you could see him?
Wow. Now, I bet that you
haven't noticed this.
On the -- that tree,
which is a Yagrumo --
Yagrumo tree, which
starts with a Y, Yagrumo.
On that tree, if you see on the
-- on the light part of the tree,
do you see a silhouette
of something jumping?
Do you see that?
It's very, very small.
That is the olinguito.
If you get to -- if you get
to hold the book right here.
If you get to hold the book, you
will see the olinguito silhouette,
very, very, very, tiny on that page.
Okay, next.
Use it. Last letter.
[ Background children voices ]
Okay.
Somebody -- somebody
that I have not called.
Have I called you before?
Okay. Where is the zoologist?
>> He's -- he's right by
under the sticks of the trees.
>> Lulu Delacre: He's
by what letter?
Tell me next to --
>> Z.
>> Lulu Delacre: The "Z."
And in Spanish --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Multiple Voices ]
So, can I read you the
last page of the book?
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Oh, okay.
I'm not reading it.
>> Yeah.
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: Okay,
so a skunk is on the prow
and startled the olinguito
stops short.
The zoologist zooms in, zooms in and
snaps a picture, a dog [inaudible].
And do you think the
zoologist is happy now?
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: Why do you
think the zoologist is happy?
Why do you suppose the
zoologist is happy right now?
Why? Why?
No, that's not this house.
That's my house.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Answer ]
Because -- Absolutely.
Listen to what he said.
Not only he saw the olinguito, he
also saw all the other animals,
amazing animals and
plants that coexist
that leave with the olinguito.
Like that amazing black and -- and
>> White.
>> Lulu Delacre: -- red bird.
That was another bird.
That was the -- that --
that was a yumbo [phonetic].
The one that I'm talking
about is the cock of the rock,
[foreign language spoken], and
I'm -- I have a treat for you.
Oh, okay. I have many treats.
Okay, listen to me.
Shhh. Listen.
I have treat number one --
I have, well, this is the very most
special treat, my box of treasures.
Oh, you are interested
in this treat, right.
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Okay.
Do -- Would you like
to see what is inside?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Something very
special, but before we get to this,
which is the very last
thing I'm going to show you,
I need to show you something else.
I am going to share with you --
Oh, let me ask you something.
Raise your hand if
anybody likes to draw.
Hands down.
So, I love to draw and I
did all those pictures.
Would you like to see a
little bit about how is it
that I made those drawings?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Okay.
So, this is my sketchbook and this
is where I have all the sketches
that ended up in this book.
This tiny.
Isn't it amazing it's so tiny?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes,
but you know what I do?
I make very tiny sketches.
You can see all the letters.
It's very hard to see.
Don't worry.
But I just wanted you to show you.
I wanted to show you my sketch book
because this is where I create books
in a sketchbook, [foreign
language spoken].
This is -- I have several
books in here.
This is where I create
my illustrations.
This is the sketch of that bird
I was talking to you about,
[foreign language spoken],
cock of the rock.
Okay, keep that in mind because I'm
going to show you something special.
We talked about the ants,
[foreign language spoken]
in that illustration.
Okay, so the sketch is there.
And then I transferred that sketch,
that tiny sketch -- I
transferred it here.
>> I see all of them.
>> Lulu Delacre: Of
course you can see.
You know why you can see?
This is the tracing
paper, and in this paper,
I drew with only a pencil.
This is what, you know,
I drew my drawing here.
I -- I drew my sketch here.
I transfer my little sketch
into this big tracing paper,
and then this helped me put
the drawing into the paper
where I was going to
paint my picture.
Would you like to see the original,
the real picture that I painted --
>>Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: -- of that
bird, the cock of the rock,
[foreign language spoken]?
Okay. I am -- This is a real treat.
I have never shown these to any,
any other group of children.
This is a super treat.
Not -- not other group of children
have ever seen this illustration
up close.
So, this is - That's where
I paint my illustrations.
That picture that you see
there, this is the real picture.
>> Wow.
>> Lulu Delacre: This,
yeah, I know, but stay --
stay back because otherwise
everybody wants to see.
Okay, I'm going to be -- It's
going to be as close as this.
This is where I painted.
I painted with many colors.
I used greens and reds --
>> Black.
>> Lulu Delacre: Black.
And do you notice something
in the background?
[ Multiple Voices ]
Oh, yeah, the zoologist.
But we talked about
the zoologist already.
[Foreign language spoken] No.
Do you know -- do you
see that background?
Yeah, does it look
like leaves to you?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Do you know -- do
you know how I did that background?
>> How?
>> Lulu Delacre: I gathered leaves.
Remember I told you I traveled
to the cloud forest in Ecuador.
Remember.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
When I was there, I gathered
leaves and I gathered flowers
and I pressed them in
between pages of the book.
And I brought them her to the United
States of America where I live.
And in that room that
you saw before,
that's where I created
the illustrations.
And those are the real
birds that I saw.
Can you tell how similar they are?
How do they similar they
look to this illustration?
And that's a photo that
I took of all the leaves,
and that's the process, see?
Those leaves that I gathered,
I used to create leaf prints.
And then I cut it out and I paste
it, that leaf print right here
in the background --
on the background.
Now, are you ready for
that box of treasures?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Would you
like to know what is in it?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: The very
last thing that I did
in every single illustration, when
everything was done, see how I went
from having just the leaves
painted to painting the birds
to finishing with the ants.
When everything was done -- Yes?
[ Inaudible Statement ]
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes, yes, yes.
I know that zoologist
is hiding everywhere.
I am going to show you
something very special.
When I was in the cloud forest
of Ecuador, I gathered leaves
and I gathered -- I
gathered flowers.
And here, I brought these leaves and
flowers all the way from Ecuador.
They flew all the way from
South America to North America.
And -- and -- We're not getting up.
We are not getting up.
I know, I know it's very hard.
I know, but we can't get
up because if we get up,
then everybody wants to get up.
So -- But I want to show
you something truly special.
Let's see if anybody can see this
from where you are
sitting down, okay?
I am going to show you
another page, different page
because this is a very neat
page, a page that has a flower.
Do you see this flower?
>> No.
>> Lulu Delacre: No, that
-- this flower right here.
Do you see this flower?
>> Yes.
>> Lulu Delacre: You
see this flower, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Lulu Delacre: Now,
what color is that flower?
>> Orange.
>> Lulu Delacre: Orange and what?
>> Red.
>> Lulu Delacre: Orange
and red, right?
Okay. Okay, now let's see if
we can see something else.
This right here --
-- is the petal of this flower,
okay, is a flower that appears here.
And there's another
game inside this book.
And that is -- We're not
going to play this game today.
You can play it when you get
the book, if you get the book
or check the book out of the
library, but this is the game.
There in every single illustration
you find hidden flowers or leaves
that came all the way
from the cloud forest.
You see this, and it's right here.
Those of you who are
close by, can you see it?
>> I see it.
>> Lulu Delacre: Okay.
We are going to -- we are going --
I'm going to show you another
page, another page, okay.
Whoops. No, that -- that's t
>> Not you.
>> Lulu Delacre: No
that -- that's me.
That's right.
That's me and that -- I'm
holding one of my other books,
and I'm with a friend of mine.
She's actually one the scientists
that helped me, Dr. Veronica Cresco.
And she lives in Ecuador.
And she showed me to --
to the collection of
those amazing specimens.
Remember the ants?
Remember the army ants?
>> Yeah.
>> That's -- Those are
the real army ants.
They are this big, this big, okay.
[ Inaudible Statement ]
The real one.
Okay, so I'm going to show
you one more, one more.
I'm sorry.
Let me show you.
You see that -- that
picture right there?
Okay, so in my box of treasures --
-- this is one of the ferns --
-- real fern that I glued into this
picture -- onto this picture, okay.
This is the real fern.
So, this, my children, this
is something that you can do.
You can go about any, any
garden near your house
and be a scientist too.
You can be a naturalist.
You can gather leaves.
You can observe the animals.
You can write all this
down, and create something
like this if you wanted to.
So, I think I'm going
to stop right now
and maybe ask you there
are any questions.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So, does anybody have a question
for me, [foreign language spoken],
in English or in Spanish.
Okay --
Did you forget?
Maybe we -- maybe we
can come back to you.
[foreign language spoken]?
Yes, a question?
>> Like, what -- I saw
flower that you were talking
about in the book and was it real?
>> Lulu Delacre: Yes.
All the -- all the flowers and
leaves that are here are real.
They are -- they've been pressed,
meaning that what I did within them
in order to preserve
them and to be able
to put them in the book for you.
So, to bring you a little bit of the
forest to all the children that --
that open -- that open the book, to
do that, that's why I pressed them
between the pages of the book.
And when they were dried,
I glue them into the --
onto the illustration, okay.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Maybe we come back to you too.
Okay, do have a question?
>> Yeah, how [technical
audio difficulty] fly?
>> Lulu Delacre: Very good question.
You know, the best way to gather
specimens like real flowers
and real leaves is
actually pick those
that are very, very, very fresh.
So when you go out in
your garden, and don't,
don't pick the flowers
that are fading.
You have to pick those new buds,
the -- the greenest leaves.
Right now that it's spring
is the perfect time to go out
and pick some flower pedals and
pick some leaves and press them
between the pages of a book that
let's say one of those paper bags
that your mom or dad have already
read that are very, very old.
So you can press them between the
pages, put a bunch of other books
on top, wait about
three or four days.
And when you open that
book, it's like treasures.
You have -- They look -- they look
like little papers,
but just perfect.
The perfect colors,
the perfect shapes.
It is amazing, and you can do --
you can create a real illustration
of the habitat that you have
witnessed outside your house
or have observed outside your
house, [foreign language spoken].
Yes?
>> My dad's from Ecuador.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Lulu Delacre: Do you -- did
you understand everything I said?
Okay, I was -- I was saying in
Spanish that if your father is
from Ecuador, you have to ask him if
he's ever been to the cloud forest
and ask him if he hasn't,
tell him the cloud forest
where the olinguito
lives is near Mindo.
Mindo is very well-known, is
very close to Quito and --
Quito, you know Quito
or your dad knows Quito.
Quito is the capitol of Ecuador.
>> My dad is from Quito.
>> Lulu Delacre: Your
dad is from Quito.
So he's sure enough must
have heard of Mindo.
You need to tell him about the
olinguito in the cloud forest.
Oh my God, he's going
to be so excited.
[Foreign language spoken]?
>> Why do you have to use
[technical audio difficulty]?
>> Lulu Delacre: Very good question.
Why is it that I'm using this?
[ Inaudible Answer ]
My goodness, I didn't have
to answer the question.
Why is it?
>> Really fragile.
>> Lulu Delacre: That's
exactly the answer.
These are specimens, meaning
that they are very, very --
they are real and they
are very fragile.
Once they are dry,
they are very fragile.
They could break.
It's almost like a very
tiny piece of -- of paper.
This is venyachag [phonetic]
which is a yellow flower.
Remember --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Look, it is dry and you can
still see it's -- it's yellow.
You can still see it's yellow.
It is small.
So I picked them up with --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
-- very delicate, okay.
One last question,
[foreign language spoken].
So this has to be a
magnificent question.
No pressure.
Oh, this is the - this is the
exact size of the olinguito.
I didn't tell you this, but this
is the exact size of -- I did?
Thank you.
I love to have kindergarteners
as helpers.
They always know.
They do. Okay, one last question,
somebody that I haven't called.
So, only raise your hand if --
if you have a question and
I have not called on you.
If I have not called on you --
if I have not called on you at
all -- the -- the little girl.
>> Why did you put the
alphabet to A from A to Z?
>> Lulu Delacre: Why did I --
>> Put the alphabet from A to Z.
>> Lulu Delacre: Because
I wanted an alphabet.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Multiple Voices ]
One more than in English and what is
the letter that we have in Spanish
that the English alphabet
does not have?
[ Multiple Voices ]
Ene. And -- and I have
to tell you a secret.
When I was a little girl, I learned
that the alphabet had more letters.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They have been demoted like Pluto.
You know how Pluto is
no longer a planet?
Well,
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They are no longer letters.
Tell you, you know, things that --
that all those people
in Spain decide.
Okay, muchas gracias, [foreign
language spoken], keep reading.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.